[Musique]
bonjour attanasio noz je me souviens le
temps vous êtes le des onze candidats
aux sénatoriales de dimanche prochain
l'heure du verdict approche comment êtes
vous à quelques heures de ce scrutin
bien ce que je motive et toujours le
dire en pleine forme même parce que
malgré les le marathon quand je me suis
imposé parce qu'il faut le dire qu'il
faut être dans la plupart des communes
même les petites communes qui ont quatre
ou cinq grands électeurs il faut il faut
y aller parce que il faut que je dirais
même séduire la gent et puis être
compétent parce que l'attelage et de
rose une question pour vous le maire de
saint joseph que vous êtes le président
de la terre saine que vous êtes mais
pourquoi vous y allez à ce scrutin
vous savez j'aime le dire je suis entré
très jeune en politique je suis et j'ai
été employé de communes de la ville de
talas ville de saint-joseph et à l'âge
de 19 ans et maintenant j'ai 63 ans
sur quoi que j'en ai vu des vertes et
pas mieux et j'en ai avalé de couleuvres
j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions
d'ailleurs c'est justement c'est parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions
j'ai eu un caucus politique assez simple
de toute modestie j'ai gravi les
échelons parce que je me suis fais moi
même et à doute qu'ils disent c'est
finalement donc vous visez le prestige
avec ce poste de sénateur mais certains
nas mais pourquoi un duo le contraire le
prestige
non je dis que thomas est ambitieux même
tout homme et toute femme
des hommes des hommes puissants de ce
pays étant président d'une communauté
d'agglomération vous avez les leviers du
développement économique de cette île
pourquoi briguer un poste de sénateur on
est considéré comme étant à tort
peut-être comme sage qui voyagent de
temps en temps et puis qui qui parle de
la république
si mais c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse je
veux encore travailler à la deux plus
hautes sphères mon pays et pour les
intérêts majeurs parce que je sens que
ça va mal
nous sommes ça va mal mais pourquoi vous
le faites en tant que président de la
cacem on va vous dire pourquoi les paris
ça fait rouler ce fameux tcsp messieurs
veulent temps je vois que c'est ça que
vous voulez venir nous ne sommes prêts
c'est sur moi et de ce côté-là je suis
clean elle l'a dit la cacem est prêt à
ta femme est prête à faire rouler mais
oui mais au delà du tcsp
oui vous êtes quand même un personnage
politique important pourtant des
décisions de vraies décisions ça nous
offre
je discute avec serge larcher le
sénateur sortant qui ne se représente
pas il disait mais ces présidents
d'agglomération qui veulent aller au
sénat j'ai envie de leur dire mais reste
et développer votre pays si en
martinique
vous savez que moi je ne suis pas
entièrement d'accord avec lui
justement dans dans les rouages même de
l'administration et du gouvernement
il ya des hommes qui sont des sénateurs
et qui devait le ministre et qui sont
députés le ministre
donc quand je suis pas d'accord moi je
dis que tout homme a le droit d'être
ambitieux mais mon ambition se limite à
aller représenter mon pays et je me sens
capable je suis maintenant un âge
comme vous avez dû de sagesse ou ou avec
le non cumul des mandats pour
m'approprier ce travail qui incombe aux
sénateurs et qui fait ce qui fera que le
pays va changer peut-être d'ici quelques
années puisque nous avons une génération
qu'il faudrait que cette génération plus
partir pour que les choses puissent
avancer parce que mon rêve c'est
peut-être utopique mais c'est de
rassembler tous les sous les
parlementaires autant ceux de martinique
de guadeloupe et de guyane pour que
lorsqu'on a déposé en commun pour qu'on
puisse réussir à 100 mais pour le moment
je veux dire que il ya beaucoup de foin
qui empêche qui est cette synergie
elle peut dire que je me sens pas très à
l'aise et comme vous dites que même si
je suis président de la cacem mais moi
je suis pas très mme suis pas très
contente de cette situation qui est ce
que vous dites que la martinique souffre
que sa jeunesse souffre que les
communautés sauf que les communes
s'ouvre est vrai pas envie de mettre un
doigt accusateur sur une personne
le président de la république également
son gouvernement qui détruisent ce pays
divisé les écoles et les collectivités
il me faut l'avouer au départ j'étais
confiant pour que ce jeune président
plus ce traître réformateur peut changer
le visage
le système parce que pour moi c'est le
système qu'il est qui a des faiblesses
qu'il est arrivé à ses limites et qu'il
faut changer de cap qu'il faut que le
gouvernement puisse faire adopter cette
année des choses avec rouen monsieur
macro oui c'est sûr mais en ce moment on
pouvait être expérimenté sage et naïf
pas naïf parce que vous savez en
politique quand même il faut un faux
vouloir osé savez lorsqu'on parle deux
ans aux et on pas enfin ce loup et non
pas du tout parce que je dis que des
fois c'est très bien sûr dans faisons
c'est un beau slogan beau slogan mais
vous savez mais ça y va aussi pour les
générations futures un faux pas quoique
nous nous sommes cette génération qui
qui est là pour pouvoir préparer
l'avenir mais on prépare l'avenir avec
quoi on est en ce moment en difficulté
financière vous avez vu que quelle que
soit la septième que soient les les
communes alors en plus
les collectivités mais être sénateur
c'est aussi le celui qui protège qui
organise justement logan l'organisation
des deux collectivités locales prises et
prise en main par justement par les
sénateurs en direct vous dirai donc aux
grands électeurs que vous allez
continuer à rencontrer aujourd'hui
encore puisque l'élection sera le
dimanche aux ont osé porter votre voix
contre sur sur mon nom c'est ce que vous
leur direz internat jeannoise des grands
électeurs qui peuvent être un peu
déstabilisés par votre positionnement
vous connaissez ensemble pour une
martinique nouvelle ni à présent cas les
comptes titres des groupes d'acteurs pmn
mécénat non je crois quand vous parlez
comme ça monsieur woerth on sait que
vous ne croyez pas à la démocratie
vous savez que les élections chicoine
j'y crois je suis je suis soyez j'écoute
j'entends qu'il ya des règles que tout
le monde est d'accord pour y aller puis
après lorsqu'on n'est pas retenue on
fait ce qu'on veut a ajouté ben non et
j'ai pas participé ni un ni un concours
n'y a d'accord d'être tirés nous être
retirés avant le jeu non c'est que dès
le départ j'avais déjà averti voyez que
moi je me sens capable de représenter
mon pays et par mon expérience parce que
j'étais maire j'étais conseil général
j'étais à deux reprises député suppléant
donc je parle de ceux de ce principe que
tout homme même si on n'a pas une
expérience politique a le droit d'être
candidat aux élections sénatoriales
c'est simplement comme c'est une
élection c'est deux sénateurs qu'il faut
des fois celui qui fait mouche aussi
beaucoup d'humanisme
c'est celui qu'on va peut-être choisir
est je pense avoir ce profil
si parce que j'ai toujours été un homme
hors des clivages
comment diable et puis tout mon jeu
nommé ni à gauche ni à droite ce qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils sont en concédant le
principe politique de parti et on met en
avant vos concepts par
vos concepts religieux philosophiques
tous les deux et plus humaine aussi puis
semaine parce que je considère que je
suis un homme du peuple
je jeu se nomme je ne dis pas que j'ai
inventé la proximité mais je pratique la
proximité avec la population quel que
soit de saint joseph ou de lamentin où
que je sois là où j'arrive et j'ai cette
particularité
je suis très à l'aise avec celui qui est
en face de moi et si c'est pour discuter
de ces problèmes
je serai forte aussi dans leur
profondeur pour essayer de trouver
solution
athanase jeanne rose il s'agira donc de
séduire les grands électeurs quels sont
les retours que vous avez lorsque vous
allez rencontrer ces grands électeurs
dans les conseils municipaux
vous savez nous avons pris cette
habitude je crois qu'il ya une certaine
évolution dans l'accueil et dans la
manière de fonctionner de la certaines
municipalités
jusqu'à ce jeu je n'ai point rencontré
d'opposition n'ait de mauvaises manières
des bouffées accueil et je peux dire que
quand je suis quand je viens toujours ma
manière joviale de d'aborder donc je
chambre quelques amis puisque j'ai des
amis dans toutes les communes donc vous
savez que j'ai joué que c'était je jouis
de cette notoriété parce que il faut
être quatre cantons et sénateurs quand
il faut et inat heures il faut quand
même avoir une certaine notoriété
et puis aussi les élus parce que nous
sommes des glaces et lecteurs apprennent
à vous connaître au fil du temps et pour
cette raison je profite de ça je dis que
je profite de ça mais aussi j'ai déjà
prouvé que je suis un homme de proximité
très bien à toutes et à tous
john rose le nomme confiant en vue de
cette élection des sénatoriales de
dimanche prochain merci d'avancé avec
nos bonnes journées
merci c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]
m